[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels wir
frühstücken heute zusammen heute gibt es
ein tolles rezept und zwar weil ich kann
oder herstellt granulat es ist eine art
knospe müsli und dafür werden wir das
nächste selbst zubereiten
ihr könnt dann in der vorab lose packen
und hab dann wirklich war es für die
ganze woche oder für zwei wochen
je nachdem wie viele essen wie viel er
zubereitet ich werde das canola jetzt
mit haferflocken machen ihr könnt aber
dafür getreide aller art nehmen dinkel
flocken gehen zum beispiel auch oder
jedes andere getreide was ihr gerne
hätte ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
grundzutaten für scajola verwende ich
300 g kernigen haferflocken 75 gramm
haselnüsse 75 gramm mandeln 70 gramm
sonnenblumenkerne 30 gramm koks chips
etwas honig zwei esslöffel olivenöl
einen teelöffel zimt und etwas salz
wichtig ist mir hier eigentlich nur dass
wir keine suche verwenden sondern einen
gesünderen zucker ich nehme thonig ihr
könnt zum beispiel aber auch agaven
dicksaft nehmen natürlich sind es auch
zuckerersatzstoffe und das ist auch
zucker für den körper aber immer noch
besser als weiser kristallzucker und
wenn ihr jetzt zum beispiel keinen honig
nimmt sondern agaven dicksaft dann ist
es ganz natürlich auch noch weg also das
können wir einfach selber bestimmen
eine prise salz kommt noch dazu den
zucker brauche ich jetzt im prinzip nur
für eine leichte süße das sieht jetzt
nach relativ viel aus aber das ist halt
auch eine riesenmenge also meist nicht
das ganze ding hier und ihr könnt auch
sagen komm ich nun einfach mal ein
bisschen weniger so wird der honig dazu
dann nehme ich jetzt sagen blumen kenne
ihr könnt aber auch im kern mix nehmen
kürbiskerne egal was ihr gerade da habt
kokosflocken oder kokos chips sind auch
eigentlich optional die könnt ihr nehmen
wir sie gerne habt olivenöl ist ganz
wichtig das war auch noch ein bisschen
fett mit dabei haben
ich würde das ganze jetzt noch mit zimt
tonkabohne wird auch ganz gut passen
oder vanille und die mandeln und die
haselnuss werde ich erst mal packen
bevor ich dazu geht einfach nur so ganz
grob da würde ich noch einen schönen
kramm tadel
[Musik]
kommen hier die nüsse auch noch mit rein
könnt natürlich auch ganz andere nutzer
nehmen macadamia und so weiter aber
damit auch zu teuer sind jetzt einfach
alles schön verbinden muss da war es das
machte am besten mit den händen
dann verteilt sich der honig nämlich am
besten und dann verteilt ihr diese ganze
mischung auf einem backblech und dann
wird es jetzt im open gerüstet so wird
schön knusprig der honig beziehungsweise
der zucker darin karamellisiert ein
bisschen und dann wird eben auch haltbar
gemacht es gibt halt überall so ein
bisschen aber man hat zumindest eine
honig kurve die hände wenn wir uns mit
den händen gemacht
wenn sie im ofen ist dann trägt es auch
ein paar mal um also für so ein bisschen
durch damit auch wirklich alles schön
karamellisieren kann
jetzt ist das granulat gepackt und es
rühren während der bauzeit wird
natürlich auch dass es schön gleichmäßig
freund und er hat jetzt schon jetzt ist
es schön knusprig wenn es direkt aus dem
ofen kommt ist es natürlich sehr weit
aber es härtet eben aus und wird
knusprig wenn es abkühlt das jetzt noch
leicht warm ich lasse es komplett
abkühlen und dann wird abgeführt und
dann zeige ich euch eine tolle missmutig
[Musik]
richtig cool und hübsche geschenkidee
und jetzt könnt ihr dieses granulat so
aufbewahren
ich zeige euch jetzt mal eine frühstücks
idee wie ich sie gerne habe ich verwende
zum fertig stellen jetzt noch eine reife
mango drei reife bananen etwas
zitronensaft naturjoghurt und gemischte
früchte die sind jetzt gefroren ich habe
zähne richtig schöne reife mango das
erkennt man auch daran dass wir schön
weich ist wenn man drauf drückt hab ja
auch noch eine dies ein bisschen
übereifrig aber ich programms tropfen
dann bist du dich weg muss ich nehme die
hier die ist noch welcher jetzt einfach
rechts und links vom großen kern entlang
wegschneiden und dann nehmt ihr euch am
besten ein glas zur müsste den banken
nämlich nicht mit dem messer oder mit
dem sparschäler schälen setzt hier am
rand an das fleisch wandert ins glas und
die schale bleibt aussen
[Musik]
und den restlichen kann man hier auch so
runter knabbern
meine schwester hat das immer gemacht
hat immer den großen kern hat sich damit
aufs sofa gesetzt und dann habt ihr
immer den kindern perm abgeknabbert das
fleisch von kern auf gegner wartet
das wollte ich sagen aber das zeige ich
euch jetzt nicht wie erhalte ich hier so
ein bisschen was für die deko übrig der
rest wandert direkt in ein gefäß zum
pürieren
da kommen jetzt noch die bananen dazu
und die dürfen auch schon richtig schöne
reif sein und weiß dann kommt hier noch
zitronensaft dazu ist vitamin c für
müsli oder joghurt und dann kann ich die
zutaten schön pürieren
und ich glaube es ist einfach so lange
wichtig seien cremes
aber wer lieber stücke essen möchte der
kann natürlich auch einfach in der küche
herum stützen denn der kann natürlich
auch einfach die mango und die bananen
in stücke schneiden damit im joghurt und
dem zitronensaft vermischen
solche kurz platz machen und dann kann
ich schon anrichten und dann nehmt ihr
euch einfach einen richtig schönen
teller
ich finde das auge isst ja immer mit da
kommt jetzt der joghurt rein wie gesagt
wer es lieber stück ich mag der letzte
start
dann habe ich hier noch die mango
schneidig in scheiben dann richtig und
da müsst ihr halt die portionen so
machen wir es gerne habt also soviel wir
morgens eben abschafft oder wie viele
essen sollte
ich glaube schaffen wird man manchmal
ein bisschen mehr als man als mann darf
so rum und bei gefrorenen früchten finde
ich's halt immer so schön da kommen
immer diese schöne weiße oberfläche auf
bildern sie das super schönes und so
sorg könnt ihr natürlich auch frische
früchte verwenden oder zum beispiel auch
äpfel oder alles was was ihr gerne mögt
das misslingt auf jeden fall mehrere
wochen werden so richtig schön
durchgerostet und es ist schön knusprig
und ihr könnt da wirklich auch eine
größere portion herstellen einfach in
eurem vorratsschrank stellen verschenken
oder einfach geben morgen genießen dass
carola schmeckt so schon richtig gut
also mir reicht da auch komplett die
stöße und ich brauche gar nicht mehr so
viel frucht süße dazu deswegen erst
jetzt auch ganz gerne einfach mit
naturjoghurt dann nehme ich gern noch
mal den zehnprozentigen und wenn ihr
wollt einfach paar früchte drauf oder
ein bisschen obst und was ihr auch noch
damit machen könnt ihr könnt auch ganz
einfach das erst sauber also einfach
auch ein bisschen sahne mit quark zum
beispiel aufschlagen
in den glasschichten des cologne als
topping oben drauf das ist auch richtig
lecker
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen falls ihr das macht dann
postet gerne eure kreationen mit eurem
müsli teller und verlinkt mich auf jeden
fall kostet diesen herr steckt runter
dann sehe ich es auch ich wünsche euch
viel spaß beim nachbarn vielleicht kann
ich mir auch ideen bei euch abgucken
ich wünsche mir schon guten appetit denn
ich hab jetzt richtig hoch und wir sehen
uns wieder auf das nächste
[Musik]